UNION ADDRESS AND MORE.
DONEE O. SULLIVAN AT THE CENTER
OF THE PROTEST IN THE CANADIAN
CAPITAL IN OTTAWA.
>> I WANT ALL THESE MANDATES
GONE, AND I'M NOT LEAVING UNTIL
ALL THE MANDATES ARE GONE.
>> WHAT IS THIS STUFF THAT YOU
CAN'T DO RIGHT NOW AS A
NON-VACCINATED PERSON?
>> I LIVE IN QUEBEC THAT'S A BIT
MORE INTENSE THAN OTHER PLACES
IN CANADA.
BUT, LOOK, I CAN'T GO SKIING, TO
WAL-MART, RESTAURANTS, CAN'T GO
TO BARS, CAN'T GO TO THE GYM.
>> Reporter: TRUCKERS HERE IN
CANADA HAVE BROUGHT PART OF THE
COUNTRY'S CAPITAL TO A
STANDSTILL RIGHT IN THE NATIONAL
PARLIAMENT.
>> I WAS HIRED ON AT A JOB NOT
TOO LONG AGO AT A TRANSPORT
COMPANY IN ONTARIO, AND I WAS
LET GO DUE TO NOT WILLING TO GET
THE VACCINES FOR MY JOB, AND I
MEAN THAT'S NOT RIGHT FOR
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE
THAT AND TAKE AWAY OUR RIGHT TO
EARN MONEY AND SUPPORT OUR
LIVELIHOOD.
>> NOW, THIS IS ALL HAPPENING
DESPITE THESE PROTESTERS
REPRESENTING A SMALL MINORITY OF
CANADIANS.
MORE THAN 80% OF ELIGIBLE
CANADIANS ARE FULLY VACCINATE
ED.
AND THE CANADIAN TRUCKER
ALIGNANCE WHICH HAS CONDEMNED
THESE PROTESTS HAS SAID ABOUT
85% OF TRUCKERS WHO REGULARLY
CROSS THE BORDER ARE VACCINATED.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
BE HERE TODAY?
>> DON'T TALK TO THEM IT'S FAKE
NEWS.
>> Reporter: DESPITE THE FACT
THESE PEOPLE MAY BE PART OF A
MINORITY IN CANADA, THEY'RE
RECEIVING A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM
CONSERVATIVES AND OTHER
RIGHT-WING FIGURES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WE'RE NOW AWARE OF A
SIGNIFICANT ELEMENT IN THE
UNITED STATES THAT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE FIGHTING, THE
ORGANIZING AND THE
DEMONSTRATING.
>> THE CANADIAN TRUCKERS ARE
HEROES.
THEY ARE PATRIOTS, AND THEY ARE
MARCHING FOR YOUR FREEDOM AND
FOR MY FREEDOM.
>> Reporter: THIS IS VERY MUCH A
21st CENTURY PROTEST, PLAYING
OUT AS MUCH ON THE INTERNET AS
IT IS ON THE STREET.
VIRAL MEMES AND SOMETIMES FALSE
AND HIGHLY OFFENSIVE HISTORICAL
COMPARISONS THAT CIRCULATE
ONLINE ARE BEING REPEATED
VERBATIM HERE LIKE THIS.
>> AND BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
VACCINATED HAVE YOU -- IS THERE
BUSINESS, IS THERE STUFF YOU
CAN'T DO IN CANADA NOW?
>> IF YOU WANT TO COMPARE CANADA
TO ANYTHING IT'S LIKE HITLER'S
GERMANY AND WE'RE LIKE THE JEWS.
ONE OF THE GOALS IS TO SIMPLY
GET A GROUP OF PEOPLE YOU CAN
GET EVERYBODY ANGRY WITH AND IN
THIS CASE IT'S THE UNVACCINATED.
>> Reporter: THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE STREAMING LIVE
ONLINE.
>> I'M GOING TO FOLLOW YOU GUYS
AND MAKE SURE YOU'RE TELLING THE
TRUTH.
>> Reporter: DOCUMENTING EVERY
MOMENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> YOU TAKE THOSE CANS OFF OF
THAT TRUCK.
IS THAT YOUR PROPERTY?
>> Reporter: IN AN EFFORT TO
CLEAR THE PROTESTERS POLICE HAVE
BEGUN CONFISCATING GAS CANISTERS
RESULTING IN ENCOUNTERS LIKE
THIS THAT CLOCK UP THOUSANDS OF
VIEWS ONLINE.
>> MY NAME IS JIM KURR AND I
CARE ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS
ESPECIALLY ONES WHO TRY TO KEEP
THEMSELVES WARM IN THEIR TRUCK
WHILE FIGHTING FOR THE FREEDOMS
OF CANADIANS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> THE MAIN PROBLEM I HAVE IS
ALL THE CENSORSHIP GOING ON.
THAT'S THE MAIN PROBLEM I HAVE.
THERE'S CENSORSHIP EVERYWHERE,
YEAH.
PEOPLE'S ACCOUNTS GET TAKEN
DOWN, EVEN FACEBOOK IF YOU DON'T
SAY THE RIGHT THING.
EVEN THIS CONVOY, A LOT OF
GROUPS STARTED AND PEOPLE ARE
LIVE STREAMING AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN I HEARD YESTERDAY IN THE
RESTAURANT MY FEED WAS CUT.
MY FEED WAS CUT.
>> Reporter: FACEBOOK SHUTDOWN
SOME PLATFORMS AFTER THEY FOUND
THEY WERE BEING ADMINISTERED BY
A HACKED ACCOUNT THAT HAD
BELONGED TO A WOMAN IN MISSOURI.
SO WHOEVER WAS REALLY RUNNING
THE GROUPS WANTED TO HIDE THEIR
IDENTITY.
AND GOFUNDME SHUTDOWN A
FUND-RAISER FOR THE TRUCKERS
AFTER POLICE TOLD THEM THE
PROTESTS HAD BEEN BECOME AN
OCCUPATION.
BUT ORGANIZERS HERE HAVE STILL
BEEN ABLE TO RAISE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THROUGH AN ALTERNATIVE
SERVICE, A SELF-DESCRIBED
CHRISTIAN FUND-RAISING PLATFORM.
ORGANIZERS SAY THE MONEY WILL
HELP KEEP THE TRUCKERS ON THE
STREET.
>> WE WANT THOSE GREAT CANADIAN
TRUCKERS TO KNOW WE ARE WITH
THEM ALL THE WAY.
>> Reporter: TRUMP INDICATING
HE'S SUPPORTIVE OF TRUCKERS
DESCENDING ON WASHINGTON, D.C.
OTHER RIGHT-WING FIGURES GOADING
AMERICANS TO ACT.
>> THE QUESTION IS HOW LONG
BEFORE PROTESTS LIKE THIS COME
HERE.
>> WILL WE NEED OUR OWN TRUCKER
RALLY TO END-ALL OF TH